the crowd there you can see the the foot
traffic going towards the left side of
your screen to the parliament buildings
the crowd there is growing larger
they are protesting not just vaccine
mandates but uh to demand an end to
pandemic related restrictions calling
for government officials like the prime
minister to resign a whole
slate of grievances that are being
protested in ottawa this morning let's
bring in michael king now for the latest
on this protest what are you seeing
michael well blake as we just heard from
david aiken they're expecting at least 2
000 vehicles the breakdown about a
quarter of those are trucks even smaller
number of those are going to be tractor
trailers with the trailers actually
attach those taking up the most space in
and around the parliament precinct one
of our camera crews has already been out
this morning people have come from
across the country bc to nova scotia
people we've spoken to some involved
citing a variety of different grievances
ending vaccine mandates for truckers
some want all public health restrictions
in place to fight covet 19 to come to an
end others want trudeau to resign some
want the opposition leader aaron o'toole
to resign some want to overthrow the
entire capitalist system but the focus
does still seem to be on the vaccine
mandate
what brings me here tired of the
mandates
sure we're sick of the mandate no
passport i want to be free in my country
in all honesty i'm kind of done with the
government mandates for the uh for the
whole border pass and everything i do
long haul over the country so
it makes my life very difficult at this
at this point in time right
so definitely some frustration but so
far that hasn't led to any violence
ottawa police say there
was no arrests overnight protest
organizers including the six convoy
captains have urged protesters to be
respectful and maintain order there have
been concerns about the potential for
violence from what officials say is a
small number of people we know the
canadian security intelligence service
is involved monitoring any security
threats
now we also know that there's been a
gofundme that has been organized about
7.7 million dollars as of this morning
organized organizers say the money is to
help with fuel food and accommodations
eight of the top fifteen donations are
anonymous including the largest of
twenty five thousand dollars made
yesterday gofundme had put a hold on the
funds until a clear plan for the money
was presented the company confirms a
million dollars has been withdrawn and
gofundme will be working with organizers
to release the rest of the funds
we're also hearing from federal health
officials regarding the protest the
federal health minister was asked about
it during a briefing yesterday he used
the convoy as an analogy stressing that
vaccinations are the best way to protect
against coven 19. now one thing that we
just heard from our political
correspondent uh chief correspondent
david aiken was part people parking on
the cenotaph at the national
war memorial he posted this picture on
twitter here's what he's talking about a
number of vehicles and an rv
parked on the cenotaph there we also
know that a number of other protests are
being planned across the country today
there's one plan for the kutz border
crossing near montana as well as the
legislature up in edmonton and here in
calgary at central memorial park